the first up he is the journalistic icon
who was associated editor of The
Washington Post his 19th book is fear
Trump in the White House we got a Bob
Woodward
[Applause]
[Music]
wage
[Music]
you must have made a fortune off this
one and you deserved it that is a good
read fear thank you and a good title
that you know you could have had many
titles but that says it that is the
essential point I think you're right
about Donald Trump fear of other things
like caravans coming and then fear of
him and what was so amazing interviewing
him two years ago he gave it to us we
asked about what real power is and he
said real power is fear and it was
almost like Hamlet in Shakespeare an
aside saying this is what it is this is
the driver and so ever since then I
thought this been out of his mouth it's
a way of scaring the bejesus out of
people that's the operating style and
his own party I thought it was very
telling that at his post-election I
guess we can call it a press conference
although it looks like none we've ever
seen before
he called out not Democrats people in
his own party this person didn't support
me enough they lost you know this we've
never you know Frank Sinatra used to do
this with critics when his older days
he'd be like this dumb broad doesn't
know a good tune when she hears it
you know this is not presidential but
that's the fear he's putting people ask
why the Republicans fall in line behind
him they feared him right yeah and I
think the country feels that fears him
and so the world fears him well they're
either in your room or love him yeah but
I think the bottom line in all of this
that the fear is worked but we were in a
governing crisis I try in the book to
deal with the substance all of
everything in foreign policy everything
an economic and domestic policy and it's
just you know he's he's gambling with
who we are in what the country is and
and could win I think you are pretty
much on my page about the fact that this
is a lot worse than people think and
they think it's bad but I keep saying I
don't think he's leaving
if even if he loses the election in 2020
and I think what you see going on right
now in Florida there's this recount he's
involved he's already talking about it a
lot I think that's a dress rehearsal for
what we're gonna see if he does lose in
2020 I do not see a scenario that we've
seen on January 20th of the next year
where he welcomes the winner graciously
I don't see that but what going back to
Watergate times in 45 years ago Nixon
what was said about Nixon was that he
had a lust for political power now we
are you know Trump understands lust to
say the least and it is part of his
being to get power over people and to
crush them to demean them and as you
point out people in his own party no one
is free from that kind of lashing
criticism and what astonished me and
we're
on this book is getting close to the
people who were close to him and the
closer they were the more they worked
with him the more anxiety and fear and
concern so they would take documents off
his desk the Secretary of Defense had to
say because trumps why are we doing all
of these things investing in NATO and
finally the Secretary of Defense said
well we're doing all these things to
prevent World War 3 now think about that
this is a year into office that the
president has to be tutored on what the
job is job one prevent World War three
and you know I've done this for 47 years
and when I learned about that I I got a
chill to think that that is going
through somebody's mind of oh we don't
need all this stuff let's just go it
alone let's not waste all this money
we're suckers Trump says and then you
hear it on the rallies last week
the same idea that somehow we're helping
all these people in Europe and the
Middle East by putting our troops there
and all the generals to a single person
or saying no no no this is the best
money we spend it's for our security and
he does not comprehend that Trump does
not so I know some of the people you
write about in the book
are gone now and I remember back in 2017
about a year ago there was this talk
about a sort of a suicide pact
metaphorically of course that some of
the people in the administration were
going to resign on mass and I remember
saying no that's not a good idea because
those people who would not be my choices
for the cabinet we're still better than
what's coming next
Rex Tillerson oh I miss him Gary
somebody who stood up to Trump this was
the a-team not my choices but yeah like
normal people somewhat yeah
now we're getting the b-team they talk
about red lines a lot you know sessions
if he gets fired it's a red line this
new guy Whittaker said hmm they go into
trumps finances connecting with Russia
which is the whole connection of course
red line to me this Whittaker guy that's
a red line when you start putting the
top cop of the country as just a stooge
just a guy who's there to do the bidding
of the Supreme Leader that's that's the
slow-moving code
the question is how do you run the
Justice Department which is supposed to
deal with law right as we know Trump
really doesn't care much about law he's
gonna do his own thing it is he is his
own person and we have this presidency
which is a projection of his personality
yeah
that's unfortunate yeah because he's a
malignant narcissist well and everything
goes through that I think I think that's
the root of all these he's got ideas
that I know a lot of them well yes but
they actually masquerade its ideas but
they really our views and the staff will
say where did you get these ideas and he
said oh I've had them for 30 years and
if you disagree you're wrong well end of
argument and he doesn't get them from
reading he gets them from the Department
of people as saying but I think what
reporters should start asking him is or
other Republicans what about two terms
for the president would you come out on
record and say there is no situation in
which a president can serve more than
two terms if that's not a red line and I
bet you they hem and haw well let's
let's hope I mean that would be over a
red line that that would be something
well you know people start asking them
yeah okay ask Marco Rubio he sounds like
an [ __ ] about this today but but look
if you have a lawyer do I need one no I
need a bodyguard is what I need
lawyer is not gonna cut it if they have
the lawyer well I have in the book
Trump's lawyer John Dowd yeah eight
months they work together as closely as
people can actually in their dealing
with the Moller Russia investigation and
so they go through a practice session
and Dowd realizes that Trump cannot tell
the truth right he makes up things yes
he lies yes
and he finally says I will not sit next
to you if you testify with Muller
because I know you will wind up in a
orange jumpsuit right because you won't
tell the truth and finally Dowd
concludes that you know maybe Muller has
something but that the core problem here
is and he didn't want to insult the
president because he liked the president
and he'd worked with him but he said the
real problem is you're a [ __ ] liar
Bob Woodward enjoyed you for a long time
it's uh great to get you are here it's a
great book thank you the great Bob
Woodward everybody
[Applause]